I switched my curcumin to alternating between the terriba and the liposomal
curcumin liquid. You've recommended around 4,000 milligrams daily of
curcumin but it's the dosage different for the liposomal liquid. One teaspoon
equals 200 milligrams. So yes, whatever you're taking anything liposomal you
could expect about, you know, you could take the dosage and times it by about 5. So if
you're trying to get 4,000 milligrams, you're still going to need that's the
negative about the liposomal is that it's expensive. So it's expensive because
you really get on average about five times the absorption of capsule. So if you're
trying to get 4,000 and you're getting 1,000 milligrams or teaspoon, you're
really still need four teaspoons of it. You can do that bath out there that would
help. If you can think of about 5x as the calculating factor for the
difference between liposom and a capsule for that is about 5x. So take the
liposomal times 5 that's really the absorption, the benefit absorption rate.